- Hi, this is Sal Khan,
founder of the Khan Academy.
And I just wanted to let you
know about the Breakthrough
Junior Challenge in
conjunction with Khan Academy.
And for those of you who aren't familiar
with the Breakthrough Prize,
it's an incredibly prestigious
set of prizes awarded
every year to the world's
leading mathematicians,
biologists, chemists, physicists.
And the idea is to award
people who are literally
moving humanity forward
through the sciences
and through mathematics.
And what we're going this year
is we're going to extend it
even further where we're going
to have a Breakthrough Prize
for high school students.
That's what the Breakthrough
Junior Challenge is.
And the idea is, is to award
people who can explain things
in a new and innovative ways.
Ways that can open up all of our minds.
Because the big breakthroughs,
the types of things
that the Breakthrough Prizes award,
these all start with new insights,
new ways of looking at the universe.
And these new ways of looking
at the universe often happen
with the people who are
just starting to look at it.
It might happen with young people,
especially high school students.
So we're going to give this prize,
it's going to include a scholarship,
it's going to include a
prize for your teacher,
and a possible lab for your school.
And we're going to give this
for students who can explain
either and existing concept in a new way,
in a way that opens our minds.
Or a new idea that they came up with,
or a new discovery that they came up with.
So, it's a very exciting
thing to be part of.
I really believe that we're
going to hopefully inspire
another generation of potential
Breakthrough Prize winners.
And I think even this competition
is going to open our minds.
It's going to make us all
see the world in a new
and exciting way.
And if you win, you will come
out here to Silicon Valley,
and you will share the
stage with both people
from Silicon Valley, leaders
in the tech community,
leaders in science.
You'll share a stage with the winners
of the Breakthrough Prize.
And there'll be a few
Hollywood celebrities out here.
It's going to be televised
on national television.
So, this is going to be a
really, really, really fun event.
But most importantly, I
think we might be able
to move society forward.
Thank you.